الى قصه ملكيه بايه من المعروف ان الامير
هاري هو الذي وجه كل اهتماماته الى
الولايات المتحده لكن شقيقه الامير ويليام
ياتي بدوره لخطف الاضواء في القاره
الامريكيه ابتكارات عند نالت الجوائز التي
تقدمها المؤسسه الملكيه البريطانيه بحضور
مؤسس الجائزه الامير ويليام وزوجته
لكن الزياره عكرتها بعض الاحداث التي لا
تعجب العائله المالكه البريطانيه
الارض لن يبقى مخيما على الغلاف الجوي الى
الابد تمكن مشروع مبتكر عماني من تطوير
تقنياته تحول الغاز السام الى صخور تدفن
بشكل دائم تحت الارض
ويهدف المشروع الذي حمل عنوان 44 فاصل صفر
واحد الى معدنت مليار طني من الغاز السام
بحلول عام 2040 وهو واحد من خمسه مشاريع
فازت بجائزه ارتشات التي تقدمها المؤسسه
الملكيه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
مؤسس الجائزه الامير ويليام حضر وزوجته
اميره ورز كافرن حفله توزيع الجوائز في
مدينه بوسطن الامريكيه حيث استلم كل فائز
من المبتكرين الخمسه مليون دولار قيمه
الجائزه الخاصه بحمايه الطبيعه والمحيطات
والتنوع البيولوجي واصلاح المناخ
من كينيا فازت شركه ناشئه توفر مواقف
للطهي تحد من التلوث الداخلي غير الصحي
ومن الهند فاز بجائزه ارشاد حلل رائد
يساعد المزارعين على خفض التكاليف وحمايه
سبل العيش في بلد على الخطوط الاماميه
لتغيير المناخ ومن استراليا تمكن مشروع
لحمايه الشعب المرجانيه بالفوز بالجائزه
كونه قدم بيانات مهمه حول مواقع محميه
جمعها من خلال مراقبه التغيرات في اعماق
المحيط كما فازت شريكه بريطانيه لعملها
على تقليل النفايات عبر صناعه بديل
للتغليف البلاستيك من الاعشاب البحريه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ولتناغم مع الموضوع ارتدت الاميره كيت
ثوبا اخضر مستاجر اذ اظهرت دراسات جديده
ان استئجار الملابس ساهم منذ عام 2010 في
خفض انتاجها ما وفر اكثر من 60 مليون
جالون من الماء و 44 مليون طن من انبعاثات
ثاني اكسيد الكربون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لكن حفل جوائز اورتشات ولقاء الامير
ويليام بالرئيس جوبايدن وزياره الاميره
كايت جامعه هارفرد العريقه على هامش
الجائزه عبرتها اتهامات جديده للقصر
الملكي للتمييز العنصري بعد تداول وسائل
الاعلام مزاعم بريطانيا من اصل افريقيا
قالت انها تعرضت لاستجواب عنصر اثناء
تلبيتها دعوه لزياره قصر بانهام
وروجت شركه نتفليكس لبرنامجها الوثائق عن
الامير هاري وزوجته ماجن الذين تخلي عن
منصبهما في لندن اثر ضغوطات النفسيه عانت
منها ماجن بسبب اصولها الافريقيه بحسب
زحمهما صحيفه نيويورك ان سكان مدينه بوسطن
التي تعد معقل الثوره الامريكيه ضد
الملكيه كانوا مستعينا من الزياره تاره
بسبب اتهامات التمييز العنصري وتاره نظرا
للازدحام المروري الذي تسببت به زياره
الامير الى المدينه لصباح العربيه هند
ابراهيم